ми стежитимемо за розвитком ситуації а
що буде з донецькими та луганськими
вузами, які залишилися на
окупованої території чи отримають
студенти дипломи або після закінчення вищої
школи залишаться жебраком на ці запитання нам
відповіла перший заступник міністра
освіти та науки України та насос він
не на увазі маяки
дипломи плану і вдова тотема ти на
університету міккі чутність на
території там ще гора
матиан звідки це ж супер і що ви
даєте біля воріт, що будуть видаватися
дипломи
донецька народна республіка челочка
народної республіки даєте продав
проживання режиму ти про те, що будуть
видані дипломи російську фотографію
розум steam гіршу на так ти шо у
російської федерації містер сулу свити
Російська федерація подумалося чого
потрібні будуть вдаватися нікуди податися
йому не просто щось там з них
Університеті барана будуть приємного to see
кафелі сьогодні янщик рок і мене будуть
животів ціна на премію
там кут говорити про те, що будуть
видаватись російський диплом це
однозначно не виправдається вже з простого
на саму російську федерацію
розгортаюся і чон інджі варіант
створення дипломів з народного набуття
республіки лансика народну республіку
стежка читку судом ледве тягнеться диплома
не так я заміжня і видно днр і лнр
дізнаватись з вони будуть прочитані піти
ви ще й китам за вийшов із синіх то
пізнавати не буду я думаю що ці русі і
їх не будуть впізнавати в частині не з них
університеті в сунув його в глухому куті в
одному з великих початку його кує в
класі з прийшло finance.ua new
balance компе йшло булонському прийшло
подали по
шевченко паличка і пішло на цю тему
нам навчаюсь не треба ось цього донатики
на фінальний blend кроків у паралель
куди хто його курка дуже краще виїхавши
на 8 університет то якші виїхала до 60
70 осіб таких обидва зареєструвалися на
виїзд ми розуміємо ще в баку кутку
підкати виїзд а
винний у процесі свистну так це мало
виїхати адміністрація мало вихід чистий та
на виплати chef алаєва комірнику trezor
і зірвалася з чим вона хоче виїхати
алла іванна інша до виїхав ще
фізичною допомогою на нас наш лежить лого
на нас можуть продумати про спосіб нібито
висоту сім'ю і так далі там
сам цьому шкіряними чекати які виїзди
віджет включено до процедури реєстрації
з там ще по батькові яко частка їх них
викладаю готові виїхати до часто
студенті готові вихід під донецьком
національному про циpку вказаних баф 5,75
через зростання данте вісарі доповіді чіп 570
висоцький болотах хто хоче ви поїхали за
принципі тиші поки що знаки такі ось
ціни знаєш його носити язичного їхав і
допомогою цей вже склад на олл-ін ці
цифри знайти мою стрічку і ми скла і фар
мого бюджету не захід і до казначейства
це важка на кіль кіст їх то
фактично виїхавши вона кінг естетики
закопали строго лисою співою будинку на продаж
не вихід а там ще пшона і зорі
стиралася входу мані з відомого
пропажа її ви їх а то відрахування в моєму
розуміє також моїм запасним зарплатам
стипендії та зарплати жопу накладка івану
дорна купила чи просто не можуть або
немає грошей або небезпечно знову ж таки вони можуть
просто бояться 3 або пересуватися по
вулиці але я скажу так само міністерство
чіпатися чоловіки найкраще видно зубрила
і їх усі припуски на суд
на ній акція начальник не може виїхати
дав можливість виїхати на доступні
початковий рік тут сара хватом ці плату
за на судний початковий рік з цим можна
продумати атаку з
йому так ladies танцювала зараз на
проблем залишити заснував і крапелька сюди
просто накласти ви їх, а то я б їм
здавалося зв'язуватися зі своїм
університетом та
ну з і просто цей що перша на
заочну форму начальника 6 така
що прагнуть так і ставків же це
початковий процес та університеті та
вокуева їм ванни при найважливішій scizor
через провалювання дистанцією на
спочатку і ще туди перебуває в
донецьку пропустим овен може вивчена
виїхати лавин може супермен за
університетом та молодість плюс
дістаньте іншу форму начальник особливого
теку вокуева на них владно на центр
сад і навпроти дихайте горошини з вини
журі ти просто також доступна рекут їх
детально вимагав та повторно згуртуватися
тут у трапа під його проти то ціна
питання суші-бар зумієш свою розшивку
означає свою ж під патрокл і там вона
вже ви курс ти не університету але тут
просто для запуску год на право на
святом а приніс збиток сам пішов вишивки
гай накоїв а якщо не може хоч
цілий віз наприклад донецькими це них
величезна база саме у місті ось вони
можуть виїхати хоч може і хочуть
що робити цим університетом якщо вони
навіть коли це є індивідуальним
порядку до студента з'ясовувати проводиться
до
інших маткових нам чорних захопивши нині
території країни
викладок може сука ту роботу там саму
там ще там завершилася цю тему з
магічному нірс цьому саду
сконцентрований це мер їжака
цьому завершилася перестаньте і там у
принципі є на виставка
щось ставка там тому що на жаль
нічого venture ми теж зароблені можемо
у нас і продовжуватиме працювати по
українці
програмі та приймати всі іспити та
інші нормативи
згідно з українським законодавством
адже мінімуми на можемо, це зрозуміло
знаходите інформацію дулю супер ці слова
то й тут ми на це може означати йому
довіряти такому не завадив дунайською
зазвичай ціна нашому предку вони що це
міністерство охорони здоров'я тортурної
Але на цьому роблять вдалого
проблема з технічними спеціальностями від
насичених університетів проблеми там
ще на таку ж базу лабораторії всi
інші там ці ці проблеми і ну і як
єдина альтернатива c-tick перекладу не
види візуального порядку і просила що
вони в індивідуальному порядку
помади на вищому з дорівнює а ось я чесно
скажу на прогалах біля сина
університетом означених найскладніший
прослуховувати для матричних орально б
там реально спішилася і кількох зі
студентів з enjoy вищим тут вона нікуди
на знак ліван і
cooper з тилу щоб порадити цим
фізичний з якихось своїх причин не
можуть виїхати з території, а то це я
новачок своєї моральних чую будемо з
тішить ця машина частини вона була в
ситуації з одягаючись нікуліну
перевзутися
вже можна сказати так що натиснули
ситуація у краї не складається таким
чином ще
реалізувати свої права на світлі
знаходитесь на території вона зараз не
може і вчитель наперед нашу коти
для того щоб їх від і продовжити
анапчани на ми тут ні слуху боку з робом
санвузли вистоємо щоб ванни за
максимально запитаний йому процедур і без
виманюють над мирними папертями
документі у взятці ви все краще дізнався і
панувати сьогодні вордстат ми раби
muse спрощену процедуру п розкладу не
я з шляху ви далі по 1 голодування коли
визнаєте і всі g тут ми за слово букву
зі злість на очі доскаче та реалізація
права на святе над їхніми територіями ми
на сьогодні нас помажемо